on
santé la grève des internes et des chefs
de clinique piétine le désaccord
persiste
oui aux nationalisations oui aux
privatisations jacques delors se
distingue la libération de nelson
mandela plus que jamais à l'ordre du
jour notre invité vrai timbre est en
bacs
la balade australienne de noah trois
sets pour battre peine force
en demi finale il sera opposé à lendl
bonsoir bonsoir brett hull breitenbach
vous êtes ce soir dans le 19 20 notre
invité vous luttez depuis fort longtemps
contre l'apartheid en afrique du sud et
vous attendez comme nous la libération
la nouvelle en tout cas de la libération
de nelson mandela le gouvernement sud
africain devait le décider aujourd'hui
peut-être aurons-nous une confirmation
au cours de ce journal avait bon espoir
oui je suis bien ici je ne sais pas qui
sera libre dans très peu de temps très
peu de jours je n'ai pas d'espoir de
savoir ce soir même je crois que ce qui
est important de dire tout de suite ce
qu'il faut qu'on en finisse
qu'on laisse partir ses dogmes qui
attend pays qui a tant donné d'abord
l'homme de père de famille le mari et
ensuite qu'on libère le peuple sud
africain
vous restez avec nous bien sûr nous
reviendrons quelle que soit la décision
sur le sort de nelson mandela
mais auparavant faisons le point sur la
situation dans les hôpitaux français les
internes en grève doivent en effet
décider s'ils poursuivent ou non la
grève des urgences ils sont réunis en
assemblée générale
depuis une heure et demie à paris nous
retrouvons sur place marie-claire tiers
après trois jours de grève d urgence les
internationaux réunis en assemblée
générale pour savoir quelle suite devant
donner à leur mouvement
est-ce que c'est pas une façon de
reculer moi non pas du tout on a donné
deux coups de semonce compass a été
entendu on ne peut pas rester
éternellement quand les urgences on va
le voir l'assemblée générale peut-être
je ne sais pas encore d'autres moyens
d'action âgées de toute façon vous avez
décidé de faire une grève des soins
c'est un recul quand même un rapport au
groupe des urgences
non je crois que tous les moyens à
travers l importance est sauf peut-être
continuer le mouvement et dire que nous
a claqué une portion la toei
consécration des chèques pour l'instant
il ya une sensation progrès france david
ferment dès qu'ils salon de tout le
monde
les syndicats médicaux comptait faire
appel à un médiateur
bonjour à tous les moyens sont bons pour
arriver c'est possible bien il semble
assez désabusé nous aurons peut-être
d'autres nouvelles avant 20h vous l'avez
constaté grâce à marie claire tiers
c'est un terme sont toujours réunis en
assemblée générale et quand ils
prendront leur décision elle sera peut
être définitive avant 20h évidemment
marie-claire tiers nous appellera et
nous dira ce qui se passe précisément
vous découvrez un nouveau dessin de bap
notre caricaturiste du 19 20
espérons que l'état de santé des
médecins
c'est à dire leur profil de carrière
comme le dit à sa manière bape
s'améliorera très vite une petite phrase
qui fait du bruit
elle a été prononcée hier soir à l'heure
de vérité sur antenne 2 par jacques
delors
le président de la commission européenne
estime que l'arrêt des privatisations
comme des nationalisations est une règle
trop rigide
on aimerait bien connaître la réaction
de françois mitterrand il n'a rien dit
aujourd'hui le président de la
république lorsqu'il était candidat à sa
succession en 88 avait bien affirmée
dans sa lettre aux français il n'y aura
ni privatisation ni nationalisation
c'est la fameuse formule ni ni qui
faisait figure en quelque sorte de dogme
un dogme désormais écornée par jacques
delors que je passe t'il michel le maire
jacques delors at il décidé de prendre
ses distances avec le président si l'on
s'en tient à la lettre du texte un peu
l'impression que ça donne
il faut transgresser la loi nous dit
jacques delors vous êtes intéressés paul
à la psychanalyse en politique pour le
mot même de transgresser l'idée est
forte transgressé la loi france grèce et
les tabous transat et les interdits on y
regarder de plus près les choses sont
tout de même beaucoup plus nuancée que
ce soit des hommes comme pierre
bérégovoy louis mermaz qui ne sont pas
des ennemis déclarés de l'elysée ils
reconnaissent tous deux que cette loi
n'est pas éternel en réalité ce dossier
des nationalisations a sans doute été
l'un de ceux qui a le plus saint
beaulize et la protée des luttes dans
les années
80 avec une passion parfois inouïe
aujourd'hui les esprits se sont calmés
on peut aborder ce problème de manière
pragmatique c'est ça la vraie révolution
chacun peut aller à son rythme jacques
delors 8e aller très vite
alors il ya un autre événement mais qui
est un petit peu passé inaperçu
aujourd'hui en tout cas dans la presse
et la présence de simone veil sur le
plateau de l'heure de vérité alors que
se passe t'il eu cette fois au centre
est-ce que de l'or rejoint le centre
droit ou est ce que simone veil rejoint
le centre gauche
c'est vrai que l'idée d'ouverture était
totalement au point mort l'année
dernière et on sent bien depuis quelques
semaines que l le commencé à renaître
il y à jean pierre soisson qui se démène
beaucoup l'association des démocrates
qui se réunit au dimanche prochain et
jacques delors lui qui n'est pas resté
inactif
alors il a beaucoup d'atouts dans son
jeu pour se positionner comme il les
foyers comme il l'a fait hier soir à la
fois en rassembleur et en sommes à la
recherche de consensus fort alors il est
sans doute née dans l'esprit de pas mal
de gens en voyant ce plateau l'idée que
simone veil -le aux côtés de roland
dumas que jean françois poncet aux côtés
de pierre roques
ça faisait peut-être un gouvernement
tout à fait présentable
on est loin d'en être là mais il faut
dire que cette idée va renaître dans les
mois qui viennent et que j'avais alors
ne sera pas absent de cet enjeu merci
michel nous attendons toujours la
confirmation de la décision que doit
prendre le gouvernement sur le sort de
nelson mandela ou plutôt sur la date de
sa libération c'est semble-t-il une
certitude nous allons parler avec vous
britten britten bac mais regardons
ensemble si vous voulez bien le dossier
que francine raymond a réalisé sur la
vie du leader noir en prison je vous le
rappelle depuis 1962 francine raymond le
8 janvier dernier winnie mandela rendez
visite à son mari dans sa résidence
prison près du cap pour la première fois
elle est sur la libération de nelson
mandela attendu depuis 28 ans n'est plus
qu'une question de semaines
en 1964 le chef de file de la haine
c'est le principal mouvement de lutte
contre l'apartheid en afrique du sud
nelson mandela est condamné à la prison
à vie pour sabotage et trahisons au
cours de son procès
son monde est là prononcera un violent
réquisitoire contre le régime raciste de
pretoria qui depuis 1948 a inscrit dans
sa constitution
le développement séparé des races en
afrique du sud un réquisitoire où il dit
sa haine de la discrimination raciale et
qui pendant 28 ans servira de référence
au peuple sud africain dans sa lutte
pour la liberté
malgré son isolement le prisonniers du
pénitencier de robben island devient
célèbre dans le monde entier
nelson mandela refuse le préalable mis
par pretoria à sa libération
la condamnation au par l'insee du
recours à la violence contre le régime
de l'apartheid
winnie attendre à 22 ans avant de
pouvoir toucher la main de son mari en
88 le plus vieux prisonnier du monde et
placé en résidence surveillée
il a enfin le droit de recevoir ses
enfants et ses petits enfants
la pression internationale est forte le
leader historique de la résistance noire
est devenue un plaisancier bien
encombrant pour le gouvernement sud
africain qui va s'employer à banaliser
sa libération en juillet dernier la
surprise
le président pauthe a rencontré nelson
mandela les autorités sud africaines
sont prêtes à se contenter d'un
engagement de sa part en faveur de la
paix pour lui rendre sa liberté nelson
mandela est d'accord à condition qu'un
dialogue s'établissent entre le
gouvernement et l'insee en octobre
walter sisulu et six autres dirigeants
historiques de la mc qui eux aussi ont
passé plus d'un quart de siècle derrière
les barreaux sont remises en liberté
on sait depuis que le principe de la
libération de nelson mandela et à qui la
question est de savoir quand et dans
quelles conditions
vettel breitenbach à votre avis sur
at-il vraiment libéré à partir du 2
février
je crois qu'on va en hausse le 2 février
date de sa libération
on devrait ce mot c'est énoncer ce qu'on
compte en faire céder le contexte dans
lequel on va le libérer je pense que le
procès ne claque on va essayer de
répondre aux propositions très précis
formulés par a ainsi salué le processus
de négociations la richesse la paix qui
était formulée par pendant il s'est
entraîné par des pays non alignés par
est paru il ya il répond on a pensé le
nombre de formules dont je pense une
formule de comité de sages
j'aimerais bien que les médias fassent
partie jusqu'où peut-elle et mandela
dans ce rôle de médiateur qu'on attend
de lui entre l'ancien gouvernement sud
africain je pense que le terme médiateur
ne serait sûrement pas celui qui sera
utilisée par mandela serait d'abord le
rassembleur de toutes les questions sud
africaine la majorité des sud africains
donc parce que la quasi totalité des
noirs les métis les indiens y beaucoup
de blancs aussi qui se reconnaissent
dans cette mouvement de masse
démocratique en opposition la résistance
à la partie je crois que c'est à partir
de là pathé distribution de force qui va
entamer le dialogue avec avec les
régimes actuels alors plus loin britten
breitenbach que mandela libéré il joue
ce rôle même si vous récusez ce terme de
deux médiateurs anticipons vous imaginez
une cohabitation
j'anticipe dans le meilleur des cas un
passage relativement rapide sans trop
d'heures vers une gouvernement
multiraciale rien n'arrêtait centif du
peuple sud africain où mandela jouera un
rôle de premier plan
j'anticipe la pulsion de précédents
d'une première république démocratique
libre et non raciale sud africaine pour
nation voilà
madiba c'est comme ça qu'ils signent ces
lettres mandela vous avez déclaré au
monde en quatre-vingts vite il faut
rompre les relations avec le régime sud
africain
c'est le seul pays au monde où le
racisme est constitutionnelle est-ce que
la libération de mandela vous fera
revenir sur ses positions
je crois que c'est pas le moment de
lever le pied
il faut être très très vigilant diffuse
sa voix que la libération de mandela
s'inscrit dans un processus est restée
centaine de prisonniers politiques qui
restent les dizaines de personnes qui
attend la mort dans le couloir de la
mort dans nos prisons doctoriales il
reste les organisations exilés et reste
l'état d'urgence il reste l'armé dans
les temps de jeu donc ce n'est pas le
moment de créer victoire et ce tous pas
donné le profit à monsieur de clerck
pour ce geste qu'il doit faire qui n'a
pas de choix de ne pas faire
vous êtes à breitenbach on vous
retrouvera hambourg et invitera quand
nelson mandela sera effectivement
libérée avec joie merci réconfort
précieux pour mikhaël gorbatchev celui
de george bush le chef de la maison
blanche est conscient des difficultés
que le numéro un du kremlin subit en ce
moment c'est la raison pour laquelle il
a tenu à le soutenir aujourd'hui
publiquement
mémona hintermann laisserait chose le
choc explique le président américain
fait face à des problèmes techniques
mais je ne veux pas faire de prédictions
explique bush
j'espère que non seulement gambade
chauffe survivra politique non non non
les sauvages
chrysler est fort la pérestroïka
continue
si le trader et ses enfants
l'intervention militaire soviétique en
azerbaïdjan a reçu l'appui de l'amérique
dès lundi cette intervention était
nécessaire pour rétablir l'ordre avait
déclaré à communiqué du département
d'état
mais le fait que le président américain
a bien appuyé personnellement public
bord le numéro un soviétique montre à
quel point la situation en use avec les
autorités américaines
c'est vrai que l'importante communauté
arménienne aux états unis doit être pour
quelque chose de faite approbation mais
plus globalement de l'amérique a besoin
elle aussi de gros macho et de
gorbatchev assez solides pour pouvoir
négocier notamment sur les questions de
désarmement et c'est donc le réalisme
qui prévaut aujourd'hui l'essentiel pour
lui comme pour les etats unis c'est la
stabilisation de la situation triste
nouvelle la petite mode est morte
atteinte de mucoviscidose est lutter
contre la mort depuis le 7 janvier à
l'hôpital d'enfants de la timone à
marseille
elle devait subir une greffe du poumon
et du coeur ses parents avaient lancé un
appel public mais il est trop tard
aujourd'hui il ya chaumont le dernier
regard souriant de la petite mode un
visage qui avait provoqué beaucoup
d'émotion dans la france entière
atteinte de mucoviscidose pendant plus
de 17 jours la petite fille à lutter
contre la mort à l'hôpital de la timone
à marseille en phase terminale de la
maladie mode devait subir une greffe des
poumons
malgré l'appel publique lancée par les
parents de la fillette médecins et
banque d'organes n'ont pas réussi à
trouver ratant un donneur compatible
plusieurs familles avaient proposé de
donner un poumon de leur enfant en bonne
santé mais le don légal d'organes
interdit de prélever un poumon sur une
personne vivante
douze jeunes enfants attendent toujours
en france des donneurs les victimes des
attentats seront sur désormais d'être
hamdani indemnisé par donc décision
prise aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres les précisions de jean paul
girouard éviter aux victimes de se
perdre dans les dédales de la justice et
de ses procédures les accueillir mieux
leur simplifier les indemnisations
voilà l'esprit des mesures annoncées ce
matin par pierre arpaillange
concrètement elles vont s'organiser sur
quatre axes principaux
d'abord un renforcement des structures
d'accueil les centres des deux victimes
vont être créés dans les trente deux
départements où il n'en existe pas
encore
ensuite une responsabilité financière
accrue des délinquants à l'égard de
leurs victimes
un agresseur pourra par exemple être
obligé de verser l'indemnisation s'il
veut bénéficier d'une peine avec sursis
les dommages corporels subis à la suite
d'agressions seront indemnisés mieux et
plus vite
enfin les victimes d'attentats accède au
statut de victimes civiles de guerre
surtout un projet de loi va être déposé
pour qu'elle puisse se constituer partie
civile dans les procès des terroristes
et victimes sont les grandes oubliées
des procès car en dehors de
l'indemnisation de la réinsertion
professionnelle et de l'aide
psychologique ce qui est important pour
une victime c'est que la justice
reconnaisse leurs droits et la présence
des victimes dans un procès
très importante psychologiquement 80
victimes espérer exercer ce droit dès
lundi pour le procès des attentats de
1986 elle ne le pourront sans doute pas
la législation arrivera trop tard
troisième audience aujourd'hui du procès
des deux policiers accusés d'avoir
matraqué à mort subite
malik oussékine audience déterminant
nous apercevait la sur l'écran le témoin
numéro un il a été entendu cet après
midi il est le seul à avoir assisté à la
scène mais il a refusé de parler à la
sortie des assises il vient de sortir à
l'instant l'image nous parvient il
s'agit de paul bezes long un
fonctionnaire au ministère de la
coopération il a 30 ans il a tout vu
il a tout dit cet après midi mais il n'a
rien dit à la sortie
le récit de l'audience elise lucet lille
7 heures cet après-midi tout à coup la
salle d'audience se remplit et le
silence s'installe 24 heures après la
date prévue
le témoin numéro un s'avance vers la
barre lève la main et dit je le jure et
la vérité qu'il jure de dire est dure à
entendre je venais de faire entrer malik
oussékine quand deux policiers m'ont
empêché de fermer la porte ils se sont
engouffrés dans le hall et se sont
précipités sur lui à ce moment-là malik
est terrorisé il s'est réfugié au fond
du hall et moi j'ai très peur claude
besson poursuit il est très calme
son témoignage est précis il choisit
tous ces mots avec soin les mains
croisées derrière le dos à ce moment là
les deux policiers le frappe d'abord à
coups de matraque sur la tête
oui il le frappe avec beaucoup de force
monsieur le président puis malik
s'écroule peut-être pour se protéger je
ne sais pas il le frappe à nouveau à
coup de bois de cette fois dans le box
des accusés
schmidt et garcia le regard 6 les mains
crispées sur la barre ils sont inquiets
un bel exemple de tolérance aujourd'hui
en france des chrétiens des juifs et des
musulmans ont lancé aujourd'hui un appel
contre la discrimination raciale et
religieuse tous leurs représentants
laïcs et religieux ont tenu ensemble une
conférence de presse et nous avons
choisi d'illustrer cet appel en nous
rendant dans une école parisienne pour
tenter de voir si le racisme comme
certains le prétendent est inhérent à
l'homme la réponse est évidemment
réconfortante évidemment évidente non
nathalie darrigrand et christophe airaud
l'ont constaté dans une classe de 20
enfants 15 entre eux sont étrangers
annie auquel viennent du maroc d'algérie
d'afrique noire d'haïti ou tout
simplement du xviiie arrondissement de
paris
mais tous savent ce que cohabiter veut
dire qu'elles ont contraint du panel
bien faire et aucun problème pour que
tous ces enfants cohabitent jouent
ensemble
véritablement il ya aucun problème plus
problématique en revanche le travail
certains ne parlent pas ou très peu le
français chez eux
or ici comme dans tous les cours
préparatoires il faut apprendre à le
lire et à écrire
fini les livres on ne vend pas écourter
le temps où la méthode par comme des
étrangers qu'ils ont tous besoin de la
maîtresse surtout dans ces places là
c'est encore sans qu'en plus la demande
est très forte
fo nou présence personnelle pour chaque
enfant et pour quel que soit travail
dans cette classe 2 ou 3 enfants
seulement risque le redoublement une
volonté des enseignants qui parlent eux
de seconde chance
une mise au point du pdg de l'a3 et de
la 2 après sa mise en cause par le
canard enchaîné aujourd'hui le journal
satirique le soupçonne de cumuler son
mandat de président de chaîne publique
avec le titre de gérant ou
d'administrateur de plusieurs sociétés
privées
philippe guillôme répond je suis bien
propriétaire de parts du s d'une sci au
capital de 10 mille francs constituer le
20 mai 86 mais plusieurs mois avant ma
désignation la sfp et depuis cette date
je n'ai perçu aucune rémunération
d'aucune sorte
les précisions de jean françois grégoire
de quoi philippe guillôme et il accusé
par le canard enchaîné de poursuivre des
activités dans des sociétés privées tout
en étant président de deux chaînes
publiques sur quoi s'articule cette
accusation
le château de monte oeuvrant dans le
loir et cher d'après le canard le
président guilaume y organiser des
séminaires pour le personnel d'antenne 2
et de fr3 des séminaires facturés à la
sci montevrain géré par le pdg des deux
chaînes à 12h30 ce midi et par le biais
de la fp philippe guillôme répond je
suis propriétaire de parts d'une sci au
capital de 10 mille francs
cette sci qui s'interdit tout acte de
commerce s'est porté acquéreur du
château de montevrain deuxième volet de
l'accusation du canard enchaîné la sci
facturé à son tour les stages à public
est sa dont le gérant est d'après le
journal
philippe guillôme réponse du pdg s'est
essayé à louer pour neuf ans le château
de montevrain public et ça dont j'ai
quitté la présidence en septembre 87
plusieurs mois avant ma désignation à la
sfp et depuis cette date je n'ai perçu
de cette société aucune rémunération
d'aucune sorte
philippe guillôme qui conclut son
communiqué sur ces mots toutes
allégations contraires relève de la
diffamation
mais dans cet article le canard enchaîné
mentionne également le nom de scelta
internationale et de france morgan deux
cabinets de recrutement et de formation
où d'après le journal philippe guillôme
pourrait encore des activités mais
autres nouvelles du jour résumé par un
gourou
les anomalies magnétiques ont été
décelés près de la décharge de
montchanin saône-et-loire
c'est à cet endroit que déçu de dioxine
de seveso aurait été enfouis selon
politis le secrétariat d'état à
l'environnement indiqué que des travaux
de recherche en profondeur commence à la
semaine prochaine
rebondissement dans la sphère si ruf
hier on apprenait l'inculpation d'un
mineur pour le meurtre de david cyr ou
présents aujourd'hui son père robert
ancien ferrailleur en hiver assez savoir
que le mineur aux questions étaient son
autre fils une inculpation qui vise
selon lui à étouffer la faire david
avait été tué le 27 juin dernier d'une
balle en pleine tête
naufrage d'une vedette de plaisance au
large de la gironde le moteur de la
vague n'est tombé en panne à 10 km des
côtes
la vedette a chaviré sous l'effet
conjugué des vagues et du vent avant que
les secours aient pu intervenir
un passager a pu regagner la côte à la
nage des autres et sont morts un
quatrième est portée disparue très belle
victoire de yannick noah en quarts de
finale à melbourne aux internationaux
d'australie le français a battu le
suédois en force en trois sets
caroline since à apprécier en
spécialiste non la cent à l'heure malgré
la chaleur pernfors arriver là grâce à
la disqualification de mcenroe n'a rien
pu faire
victoire du français en trois sets 6 3 7
5 6 2 le public australien jubile son
chouchou fait des merveilles à sydney il
battait lendl alors pourquoi pas ici en
demi finale
pas impossible pour jean paul loth
directeur technique national il est
revenu à son meilleur niveau de tennis
donc le problème maintenant est de
compter parmi les trois ou quatre
peuvent que c'est des trois ou quatre
qui en échange gagné les tournois du
grand chelem j'entends par là c'est la
ndp accès becker s'est éventuellement
wilander il se remet à jouer avec envie
et puis tout de suite là il ya yannick
maintenant inquiets
la façon dont il joue au tennis en ce
moment laisse aucun doute il ferait
situe dans les cinq meilleurs joueurs du
monde en niveau de jeu ce journal c'est
maintenant terminé ma recrutement vous
présentera ce soir soir 3 dans quelques
instants florence plein vous dira le
temps qu'il fait aujourd'hui en france
ou qui fera demain en france et en
europe à demain donc à 19h pour un
nouveau 19 20 après le journal de 12h45
que vous présentera and de coups de 9
bonsoir à demain